encounters. And today we're going to present information on what we call our Eden's diet.
The Eden's diet is a low glutamate, low-bethiety diet, which is where do you find glutamate and
methyonide? They are amino acids and amino acids are what make up protein. So based upon your genetic
profile. So your cancer patient might, we've already given you a mixed diet if we haven't gotten
back your genetic profile. When we get your genetic profile, it's going to give us some hints
or clues to what could possibly be the fuel line or what is feeding a person's cancer.
So based upon your genetics, we get clues on what's feeding your cancer. Now again,
we want to cut off the supply lines to a tumor. So the fuel supply lines, what's feeding it
in order for the law to grow is important to identify. The genetics give us some very important
clues based upon that. So a person is even is going to either have their cancer feed
mainly off the endpoint of glycolysis, which is lactic acid, which is a different diet
this one. Or it's going to feed off of methyonide glutamate, which is this diet. So if you're in that
category, this is the video you want to watch. So based upon your genes that I read, if I said you're
need to be on a low protein diet, a low glutamate, low-bethiety diet, we call that our Eden's diet.
We call it our Eden's diet because that's probably the way they ate in the garden of Eden.
So you're going to say, well, that's probably why Adam and Eve left the Garden of Eden because
they couldn't eat this way. But that's not true. So let's look at it. Phase one. You're going to do
all these phases at one time, but I'm teaching you these in different phases. So again, this is not
a complete substitute for the organic whole food diet that I already gave you. But this is in
addition to that. You're eliminating certain things. So here's what you're going to be doing.
You're going to be eating a lot of organic fruits and vegetables. Well, I've also seen a lot of sugar.
Well, that's true. But we're eating the whole fruit and the whole vegetable. And so we're getting the
fiber along with it. And remember, if we believe this supply line to your cancer is glutamate and
methionine, it's not strictly based upon the glucose that we don't want to have a lot of glucose.
That's why I'm saying all vegetables are acceptable. But you have to limit your legumes. I'll speak
more about that in a second. And I say stick to mostly pitted fruits and berries. Pitted fruits have
a lower glycemic index. You won't be spiky your glucose levels that berries have a lot of antioxidants.
So I'll get you by organic fruits and berries. Not frozen ones, not canned ones. These are fresh
vegetables, fresh fruits and berries. The acceptable vegetables are all except the legumes.
Limit your legumes there. I coined the phrase. Limit your legumes. What are legumes? Beans, lentils,
peas, soy. Nobody should be in soy any home. These have protein in it. So these are things I
can let you cheat on later. But you can't have these to begin with. So you're not eating beans and
legumes and peas and soy. So when I say limit, I mean, really you're not having those. So that's
how strictly limited you are. Bananas, yes. But on the greener side, just like I said in other
presentations, when bananas are green, they have a fiber in it that's indigestible. That's very good
as a pre-mionic. When it ripens, that fiber forbids that it just turns to sugar and it's not a
very value. Greater bananas still have the nutrient value, but they also have the fiber values. You
want bananas on the greener side. And of course, no prepared canned bottled fruit juices that are
just strictly sugar and have no nutrients to value. Phase two is your eliminated dairy. Your
eliminated eggs. Your eliminated meat of any kind. Your eliminated nuts. Remember, this is a low
protein diet. So anything that comes from a cow, anything that basically comes from a farm, except
the things that grow in the ground, you're eliminated. So no dairy, no eggs, no meat of any kind,
no nuts, a low protein diet. You're sticking to everything else on that diet that I gave you prior
to this, but now you're eliminating these things. Now you're starting to say, this is why
Adam and Eve left the garden. Well, I'm going to let you cheat. So we're going to cycle this.
We're going to cycle this diet on for five days and off for two days, on for five days and off
for two days. So your off days, maybe your weekends, maybe go Monday through Friday, you're sticking to
this and Saturday and Sunday, you're going to cheat on this. On those cheat days, you can cheat on
some plant-based protein, plant-based protein, nuts and legumes and such. Once or twice a month,
you can cheat and have some animal protein only on your cheat days, but you could have some animal
protein once or twice a month. That is your girly craving hamburger, a piece of steak or something
like that, but don't go hog wild because we don't want to be spiking your glutamate in the
thiety levels. All right, so this isn't so bad. Is it? Yes, it is. No, it's not. You can handle it.
Our Eden's diet for low glutamate, low-methiety people to cut off that fuel supply to the cancer.
You're doing great. You could do it. All right, we'll talk again on our next diet and make sure you're
checking out our Facebook page and every other piece of information we have available.